lawmakers are calling on Facebook CEO
Mark Zuckerberg
to testify on Capitol Hill about the
abuse of user data Facebook is under
fire because data for more than 50
million users was inappropriately given
to Cambridge analytical
that data firm used used it to target
political messages in the 2016 campaign
Louisiana Republican Senator John
Kennedy joins us from Washington he is
leading the bipartisan push for a
hearing with tech industry CEOs Senator
Kennedy good morning good morning thank
you for being with us what would you
want to hear from Mark Zuckerberg if he
were to make it up to the Senate to
testify
Facebook's a wonderful company but it's
no longer a company it's a country
enormous power does many beneficial
things but it clearly has a corrosive
effect
I would like to mr. C mr. Zuckerberg not
his lawyer mr. Zuckerberg in the flesh
come in and talk with us let's talk
about this listen let me ask him a few
questions to what extent if any when we
go on Facebook are we living in a
contrived world created by Facebook's
algorithms sort of like Truman in the
movie The Truman Show I would like to
know to what extent Facebook has been a
good Stewart of our data I'd like to
talk about the bargain we've made with
Facebook we know what we as consumers
get we get free access to the site what
exactly does Facebook yet and what are
they doing with it and I guess the
overarching question is how how can we
preserve the good things about Facebook
and there are good things well at the
same time stopping the corrosive effects
of Facebook is a social media platform
and other social media platforms so
senator this sounds like more than just
a response to a single incident this
sounds like a full-body exam that it's
going to take you to take a long time to
get through yes and it's worth it let me
say the game this Facebook does many
things it does in some respects bring us
closer together but in other respects we
have discovered it pushes us apart and
particularly the data the amount of data
being collected how the data is being
used whether it's being used with our
consent I mean the Cambridge analytical
stuff is you know it's kind of getting
into the foothills of creepy here and
and we need to address that and it's I
appreciate mr. Zuckerberg finally saying
something and I appreciate his apology
but but but that's that's that's not
enough we need to sit down and visit I'm
not looking to regulate him to death
but I can tell you this the issue isn't
going away Facebook and the other social
media companies can do it with Congress
or without that's their call I would
respectfully suggest they can do it the
easy way the hard way senator now you
mentioned the foot foothills a creepy
here with with Cambridge analytic a
president Trump's team used that Senator
Cruz's team used that so if this isn't
just about Facebook this is the
politicians or what's your view about
the politicians who have been dwelling
in the foothills of creepy well the the
very first successful politician who
mastered the art of mining data on
Facebook was President Obama's campaign
I mean he was the pioneer and and plenty
of politicians use Facebook to
articulate their message nothing wrong
with that and I'm not saying Cambridge
analytical did the right thing here it
it certainly looks like they're part of
the definition of creepy but but the
issue is bigger than just one media
consultant abusing Facebook I want to
know if there been other cases of abuse
I want to know how they're protecting
our data I don't want to know how
they're gonna stop the Russians from
interfering our midterm elections
senator they clearly interfered in the
last election
you bring up Russians and Mark
Zuckerberg said he didn't know if some
user data got in the hands of Russian
operatives how much does that concern
you and should President Trump bring
this up among other issues with Vladimir
Putin well
the issue is not whether mr. Zuckerberg
knew the issue is whether he should have
known the issue is whether and I'm not
saying they were whether the company was
negligent or reckless
how serious are they taking data
protection how serious are they're
vetting their advertisers are they just
saying okay let's see if the check
clears if the check clears split a
moment they sent their lawyer all the
media companies sent their lawyers till
the last hearing it was a waste of
shareholder money for the media
companies and it was a waste of our time
because their lawyers did their job they
dodged Bob we've stalled Ries Talde they
didn't say a damn thing and we needed we
can do better than that and and mr.
Zuckerberg is obviously a very bright
accomplished successful young man I have
no doubt that he'll if he'll sit down
with us we can we can do something that
will improve Facebook can I ask you
senator about another story that's been
in the news the possible leaks at the
White House the president Trump was
allegedly told in capital letters do not
call that Vladimir Putin to congratulate
him on his victory that apparently has
been linked has been leaked from the
White House what do you make of what's
going on over there and are you
concerned about it yeah I'm concerned
the president ought to be concerned mr.
Kelly Allah we all want to be concerned
it's unconscionable you know if if you
dislike the president that much and
you're still working for him you know
you don't have a soul you ought to quit
I mean mecan't be more than a handful of
people who had access to this
information and I'm not saying the
American people don't have a right to
know they do but I'm also saying that a
president whoever the president is has a
right to surround himself with people
who at least have a modicum of loyalty
and sort of have that his best interest
in the best interest of the American
people at heart at a minimum and I think
this weekend this was unconscionable
they need to prosecute whoever did it
they need to dig a big old hole
underneath the jail
put the person there because it's wrong
dual outrage on the leak and also on the
action of congratulating Vladimir Putin
Senator Kennedy thank you so much for
joining us